okay guys it's been a long count down
from 25 to hear but we danced were our
last five games the best five games of
2015 very exciting exciting on our fifth
favorite game of 2015 is Mario maker
that games pretty great right you know i
think is a very deserving entry in our
top five there has been in gaming
history a lot of games that try to do
what mario maker didn't which you know
give you the tools to actually create
levels yes great games or race tracks or
whatever mario maker is by far i think
the most intuitive the simplest it's
just really exemplified how easy this
thing is to actually get into by the
fact that everyone was so upset that
they actually lock things away when you
first played this game they had that
eight day or 12 day waiting period but
everyone went no this game is so good we
understand how it actually all works
everything is drag and drop and then
test why are you locking the stuff away
and for me you know i'm not a game
developer it made me feel like a game
developer and it made me a it gave me a
much better understanding of how hard it
is to actually make a game like market
and it's a mario game that you can make
really good levels in like there are
some bad levels in there there are some
automatic levels in there but there's
some really fantastic i was there ID act
act of playing the levels in mario maker
is super fun yeah I ain't talking about
the placement uh for me this is the
number one game because it's kind of the
all game this is a game that I don't
have to stop playing because people are
constantly coming up with imaginative in
new ways to with you what you just make
you have fun in these levels only a lot
of the top levels that you see when
you're you're playing through the game
or just experiences like I'm gonna sit
and someone has crafted the melody to
some of my favorite games or doing TV
show it's just something you get to
experience and relax whereas others are
just this incredible challenge like part
of the game is the 100 Mario challenge
which is gonna throw a gauntlet of
stages at you and
it's asking you can't you get through
this in a hundred lives and that
challenge is so much fun and I feel like
I can keep coming back to it it's always
a fresh experience multiplayer is
obviously such a really important part
of modern games and you know the Wii U
is often criticized for not being a
console that we does multiplayer really
well Mario maker isn't a game that's
traditionally multiplayer but it is it's
like it's like an asynchronous
multiplayer game in a way because you're
creating something putting it out there
and somebody else is interacting with it
and you're sort of iterating it based on
what they've done right yeah yeah I mean
you're playing with everybody you're
playing with the internet it's not just
your friends are you can make friends in
that way because you can see some of the
people who create stuff but I think I've
played with more random people on this
game than any other game and you can
enjoy it so much more because of the
crazy or wonderful or terrible things
that people are making like I think I've
made more enemies in this game like I
wish I could just actively dislike a
level and say I hate you as a person and
you're kind of a terrible even being and
it's a game that I loved even though I
didn't grow up playing mario games and I
think a lot of people when they see this
is number five in Goa this is just a
nostalgia trip you guys only like
because you played those old mario games
what would you say about that just I
mean nostalgia of course has to play
something into it because they're there
are these great memories and great games
that are associated with it but the
reason that those are so enduring the
reason that we think of as Mario is such
an iconic a character that everybody
knows that as a mascot for gaming is
because he embodies gaming it is like
the core platforming experience it's
better on a Mario game that it is on any
other platformer and kinda that's what
super mario maker does it not only gives
you the tools for creating with the best
platformer there is but it also gives
you the music and the sound I mean
you're not a developer when you're
making these games but you're a game
designer which is something that's
totally different but still an amazing
experience and that's something that
really only Mario maker has ever made me
feel
you